two this is taika's first time toasting
bread
it's not oh no oh no why does it look
like that no explain yourself why does
this look like this that was Mama's
fault that was your fault was it I guess
so it's called the butter this is butter
you put butter after
did you know that yeah did you need the
bread to be nice and warm so then the
butter melts on it I think I used the
toaster before it when I was at
Grandma's house
oh oh yeah your Eagle waffles we love
that huh
hey don't do that do you want to eat
like that no of course not you want to
kiss me
who doesn't want hot chocolate huh
that's the real question
likes he hates being happy monkey
for this morning's breakfast
we're gonna combine some of yesterday's
leftover spam action
and eggs if I could find it uh-huh right
there some eggs got some leftover rice
too
I'll just throw it all together don't
know what it's called doesn't really
matter it's Camping Time
oh can you make a garlic rice it's too
late I know we're camping babe
I don't have saffron and I don't have
craziest you want like garlic
you're drinking a mocha we
just toasted our bread and you
have a rice cooker
what are you talking
just close the mouth
I'm gonna teach you how to bite nuts
[Music]
all right just because I love this
so much I'm like you know what I'm gonna
put Garlic in there so shut up it was a
good idea admit it the idea was good and
you're like I don't know why I didn't
think about it honestly it was a good
idea because it reminded me of baby
Stacks oh they always have literally yes
literally but anyway I still love you
too
oh you're so cute see thank you I
thought you were on my side she's so
sweet you're glowing this morning
she looks all right
oh yeah L butter
the RV is planted so but it's only slide
it in One Direction
L garlic
I never really cook with food that I
actually like at home I'm always on a
diet right so just even seen like three
ingredients that look good together she
looks good
is just Spam and butter and garlic and
rice
that's it
throw some eggs in there
how do you manage to make your food look
so shitty does it does it look bad it
looks gnarly really look at all the
yolks those are not yummy go ahead so
look at that I got all that up in there
trying to do try to keep everything
simple one pot but you usually would
have had several pots going but our pans
but this camping I'm trying to do many
dishes no but honestly you're really
creative to your food
always looks gnarly but tastes the
opposite isn't this the the uh now it is
now it is yeah no now it's looking
really good
look at that come on come on now do you
think you added enough rice
that's all the rice we had oh this is
leftovers it's not it's out of my
control okay I'll give it to you yep out
of my control of what it's gonna taste
like but it looks bomb I think the I
think the cherry on top ingredient
honestly don't even say it
garlic
I was gonna say the spam okay good good
no the garlic for sure it tastes it
tastes bomb the RV smells bomb don't you
dare say anything with that did you
bring garlic salt I did I don't think
we're gonna need it because the spam is
salty yeah yeah so if it was up to me
all right David let's see this garbage
cap from this
it's like I've always wanted to know
what was like to be in prison
yeah no tell the truth tell us right now
it tastes like you don't help him it
tastes like uncooked spam with rice is
it uncooked for us
let me ask you something no no don't ask
me nothing
will you put this famine did you let it
cook and Fry first yeah a little bit
it tastes like it came straight out the
pan for reals but I actually ate it like
that oh you did
what do you think
earthquake
my Facebooks are absolutely
trash yeah so what's up I wouldn't have
known the difference but I can see what
he's saying
uncooked it has like the essence of a
dog food oh okay so it tastes like dog
food
about to head into Zion this morning
and we drove through this cute little
town
and I think Zion is that way and it
looks like the town's about to disappear
so this is our last chance to get coffee
and I was looking for like a chain like
a Starbucks or Coffee Bean or whatever
but then I saw this place oh this is
pretty cool a little drive-through
coffee action obviously you can't fit
that big mofo in there so
oh you know how I do it hey did you just
step on the flip floor oh no that means
your food's gonna be all right now is
this guy wearing jammas underneath yeah
that's cute
all right so yeah we got a little
walk-up window
go check it out
oh they got drip Americano cold brew
Powerhouse two times espresso
cappuccino white mocha chai
we even got smoothies
what was that all about
ready good fight okay
oh what the he punched my punch that's
crazy bones
my whole body
what happened
no jiu jitsu always wins
see you dead
go go go go go
the copies
and our drinks
let's see
yummy yummy
time to get the show on the road
all right guys Non-Stop
100 miles an hour
24 7 hours a day 365.
that is pretty dope over there though to
see like the clouds float so low
almost looks like Steam
that is dope
so close
but so far
I've been in this traffic for about
15-20 minutes now just to get in the
entrance
lettuce and we just want to see the
mountains
filters
it's a double-headed tiger
we are in Zion
finally in the actual one I don't know
what we were yesterday but we're about
to drive through
imagine the top half of this
artist you told me to go down the center
too
well this is a total tunnel whoa we're
going through it the inside of a
mountain you know that monkey this is
like a Disneyland ride holy
this is a tunnel tunnel
you know that no we went through the
middle of the mountain
now here we go we're coming out the
other end not gonna lie that was kind of
scary what was scary about it well he
told me
to turn the headlights on I didn't turn
them on what is going on is this is this
the part where the boulder comes back
down
oh no it's another tunnel wow yeah I
didn't know why I need my headlights on
but now I do
another tunnel a real tunnel
yeah because tunnel can be long yeah
it tells you to hold your breath wow
this is a really long time
this is gonna be a long tunnel like a
train tunnel that's David
taking pictures of the dark
you don't know what I'm doing idiots hey
a punch is Gonna Come From Any Direction
and you're not gonna be able to duck it
are you ready
and just like that there's light at the
end of the tunnel am I right
am I right
am I right yep
there's always lights
at the end of the tunnel yeah am I right
everybody
yeah
wow look at this point we had a long
line oh this is beautiful wow it's a
safety purpose
wow
wow wow wow
jaggy these rocks are yeah
all right so we're parked right there
and we're about to go and explore this
area
try to get down to some snow
let's have a snowball fight we've got
Mia walking around in the wild
got this wild animal walking on the wall
go follow Mama we got Mario
is muddy down there
is that a good thing
because we might find a creek or
something
a creek
oh
you know how to get that one how cool we
found the creek
it's right there
there's a little creek
that's pretty cool you know how to get
there
okay I'll follow you be careful young
man
and how about yourself
this guy looks warm
Target looks so warm
look at this just straight up ice chunks
you're straight up ice chunks in here
you did that yes oh you tricked me I
thought there was a melting Glacier you
tricked me so good
I was like what that's crazy bones
Mia looks like she's in her element
[Music]
hey the colors look so good
throw another one
oh careful careful dude oh my goodness
only snow
[Music]
hey monkey I found some animal poop
some animal poop but I don't know if
it's like a deer if it's a bunny but
don't get too close but he sells little
dots
that's poop hey don't touch him that's
poop for an animal that means they live
close to around here
they look like coffee beans don't touch
them though they're disgusting
I don't know if it's like a deer or a
bunny but some sort of like herbivore
you're like little but those are my
coffee sticks yeah they like coffee
beans
these shoes
came in handy they're so grippy I feel
like I can't even slip I shouldn't even
not sit back because I'm sure I'm gonna
jinx myself but the waterproofness for
these hundred dollar shoes is freaking
good check it out
foreign
erged no problem this is awesome
to keep up with that that crazy dude
over there
his whole body's waterproof
and we got a wild Mia wow
Mama's training her still we're just
getting reacquainted with her
but you guys are on treats and stuff but
go go go go play uni
wild Mia
oh she looks like a wolf
good girl
what is this wolf doing
are you in your knees in water
I'm pretty sure are your feet cold
this is for sure your son you know that
for sure
that's my son that's your side look look
how this will be deep in water
These Boots are nice
and Mia has the craziest Duty right now
excuse me hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey
what's I think she's married with us
what did you do I didn't do anything
there's a problem hit the unlock button
and uh
voila what the was that so what
happened we I was hitting the unlocked
by about 300 times and it was locked and
I was about to get ready to jump through
the window
and you left all the lights on so
hopefully our battery
what should I do to him
I don't know he's your man let's see if
this thing has any like juice left in it
that's what I'm saying but he didn't you
turn it on prove me wrong
wait
wait you
turn it on prove me wrong you want me a
if this works
oh yeah baby
so we have run into an issue that I was
trying to help Papa solve and he slapped
me in the face
that's off topic okay that's all I said
was just trying to help and he dissed me
so the meal we're trying to make today
is udon did you want to play with this
and I was trying to make it here
the problem she's talking about is the
stove it just went out I don't know why
and I was trying to make it here in
three separate pots so the presentation
is good it's our last night
and um it was heating the water all the
time it cuts out and then I'm like what
the heck I don't know what is happening
so I'm like you know what I'm gonna just
kick it old school work yesterday one
pot method it's gonna be a little messy
but it still tastes good so right now I
got the box cheesy up in the easy that's
some good veggies and then threw in some
garlic right here put some you're not
gonna cut the end pieces again so David
could break another tube no no I'm just
gonna boil it harder okay and uh we're
camping you know what I'm saying okay
and then I got the some salt thrown in
there is it gonna be an issue that it's
all Frozen like that you know what I'm
gonna stop asking questions no I won't
it won't because it's a guess
yeah so
so that's an inside joke if you were
here why are you so happy why are you so
giddy
it's so funny when you get burned it was
so good we didn't get burned because
this guy is dumb he couldn't figure out
how to burn the freaking meat with the
soap meanwhile I mean well after the
garlic
after garlic whoa that's sensitive dude
that's sensitive all right garlic how
dare you I put the tofu yeah hey this is
a very dysfunctional cooking show okay
and then the garlic the tofu and then
but so that's how you make me as food
and then I put that on there and then
you sprinkle some salt on the Frozen
beef
see that trust me this is a lot of salt
I learned how to make this in prison
[Laughter]
don't worry David
Mia you're about to eat too girlfriend
some of this half hot water in here
uh laughs
don't make fun of me please
are you a little stressed a little bit
okay
dude you're just begging like it's just
teetering you know what I'm saying like
it just seems heavy oh my God
you're gonna head down to the stairs
yeah I hope it tips over I what would
you why would you wish L upon me
that's a lot of water
that is isn't it
there's a gallon
I'm about to Chuck this camera at your
face and not even stopping it from
recording all right
that's how you make the one pot udon
is it in there oh thank God
all right
all right what's happening now because
the flannel is off it's hot it's the
Moment of Truth we're about to see it's
not that hot I just put on a sweater for
Real about to see if this one one hot
udon comes out good got the table set up
what's the water for is it for you or
for your meal for the meal okay
I am don't look at the food because it's
probably not gonna look good but it
probably tastes good hopefully
Mia your meal your meal's ready are you
serious
I think it's gonna taste good
see look at that one pot you see that
the whole thing is UDA I'm just kidding
yeah
the TVs are what are you talking about
oh I see what you did what did I do see
you try to keep everything nice and
simple
for El Campo
okay so we went from French to Spanish
and uh eating a japanese-ish meal
something like that all right how we
feeling how are we feeling you had you
had everything planned you were like
pretty good to go and then one thing
after the other the walls came tumbling
down what happened what's going on
sometimes you feel stressed right
because it's not going your way and you
kind of take it on your wife a little
bit never but sometimes it absolutely it
actually comes out pretty tasting good
am I even speaking English did you taste
this no I never did what the are
you talking about I never taste hey
David are you really hungry a little bit
hungry
you're eating chips just in case we
don't know what that tastes like
what about you you're really hungry a
little bit under a lot of hungry let's
just take it slow so let's just take it
you know as the noodles stay in here
yeah yeah yeah then just so a lot so
let's just empty it into a separate pot
no a lot or a little a medium
okay
all right
David hi you're going to die all right
I'm going to die so as I was vlogging we
smell major poop we are about to have
dinner and um yeah Mia
thank you very much
well well chef
what do we have here we got
udon that hopefully I think tastes
pretty good
um
I'm actually a little bit worried but
also not because that's just my style
and I haven't tasted it one bit so I'm
sure it'll be good
look at the people the final product
whoa it was convenient though one pot
dude whoa that's pretty convenient
one pot and if you want extra scraps
just get it off the floor with your dog
chat yeah
all right gotta cut up attack this
freaking little mouth can't handle
does he like udon he loves udon
okay here you
oh there's only one chopstick here you
get it
you get it all right I don't want to see
you do the on theirs
all right
let's see wow that smells just like pure
beef
nothing else I smell
foreign
I just I only just use ponzu oh my
God but actually comes out pretty good I
try to make it taste like the end of
shabu-shabu you're not the end of
shabu-shabu where you just have panzo
and udoni just throw yeah yeah
use a little salt oh for us oh my bad
soy sauce for me so
here's my
there we go
much better see bam look at that no I
know it's all of them
Magic
just like that that's how it's done
all right here you go I want you to sit
next to me Mama well today she wants to
sit right there
no after maybe this is so popular
because you're the popular lady
cheers
it's already in there
crazy yeah it's not bad that's good is
that warming the hearts no let me do it
oh it needs a little bit more
seasonings understood
oh my
hair yes
I actually inhaled the soup and it made
me cough immediately I couldn't even
contain it sorry Mister did I spray on
you comedy
on your slippers
oh my God what's going on
[Music]
that was a pretty good question
all right finished dinner had a CUNY
time then I went to go take a shower
and this young lady is laying in my bed
are you ready for some action
yeah
why are you laying on my bed for get out
my sleeping Arrangement is since we put
Tyco to sleep early we figured we'd put
him in the bedroom with the other room
and it is kind of cold and they can keep
each other warm like the little body
heat and I'll just leave out here
like a stranger
right
I'm trying to make sure they get along
too
but anyways I'm gonna go to sleep and
we'll see you guys tomorrow good night